alexandre touzet vice président délégué
à la prévention de la délinquance à la
sécurité également du conseil
départemental de l'essonne bonjour
alexandre touzet bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct ce matin dans
la matinale de rtl france
votre réaction tout d'abord à ces deux
décès en deux jours c'est beaucoup c'est
énorme
en même temps c'est pas nécessairement
une surprise malheureusement concédé
départementale de l'essonne est connue
comme une terre où ces affrontements
entre bandes sont récurrents c'est pour
ça qu'on demande depuis des mois des
renforts en termes de sécurité mais
aussi d'enseignants aussi les personnels
de justice pour qu'on puisse donner des
suites à ces luttes entre les bandes
alors justement gérald darmanin a dit
qu'il enverrait une centaine de
policiers et de gendarmes
c'est une première réponse selon vous
vous dites que ça fait longtemps que ce
phénomène existe que constatez-vous sur
le terrain dans cette montée des
violences
alors c'est une réponse très éloigné du
besoin pour vous dire il ya 1697
personnel de police je parle même pas de
des radars meury en essonne
nous sommes le département le plus bas
en terme d'effectifs sur l'île de france
alors que nous concentrons l'essentiel
des problèmes plus de 50% de ses
problèmes de rixe entre bandes ou wei et
qui a bien un problème majeur en fait de
présence de l'état dans le département
de l'essonne
mais ce que le tea pot les policiers ont
prédit ray un truc pour les enseignants
pour les personnels de justice parce que
il faut à chaque fois donné une réponse
judiciaire en fonction bien sûr la
gravité des faits mais une réponse
judiciaire rapide ferme et efficace et
là en l'occurrence c'est pas le cas la
réponse judiciaire se fait attendre
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
pourquoi il ya ces phénomènes de rixe
entre bandes rivales particulièrement
dans l'essonne alors en fait c'est pas
forcément concentré sur la partie sud
c'est vrai que le drame de saint chéron
est plutôt surprenant parce que c'est
une commune qui est relativement calmes
qui connaît et sur des problèmes de
sécurité comme on peut reconnaître
partout en france mais c'est pas
vraiment lui
où le collège le plus insécurisées qu'on
peut connaître dans l'essonne ces
problèmes se concentrent plutôt sur la
partie centre et nord du département
les origines de ses confits sont très
variables ça peut être d origine tout à
fait futile d'un match de foot d'une
drague
voilà comme ça peut être liés à des
trafics
donc on a des origines qui sont très
différentes mais qui sont aussi très
ancienne c'est pour ça qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à mobiliser l'ensemble des
acteurs
les forces de sécurité l'état le
personnel éducatif d'éducation nationale
les collectivités pour qu'on puisse
prendre ses mots à la racine et répondre
et ils répondent vraiment spécifiquement
sont les territoires parce que l'origine
ne sait confie dessus en sont les
territoires n'y a pas une explication
unique
gérald gordat à donner un début
d'explication
il a parlé des réseaux sociaux qui
favoriserait justement ces rixes est ce
que vous confirmez
oui c'est pour ça qu'on a notamment dans
le territoire la gendarmerie engagé une
démarche de prévention avec des sets de
table et des interventions dans les
cantines scolaires pour parler avec nos
jeunes collégiens sur les risques des
réseaux sociaux risque lié au
harcèlement risque lié aussi à la
surenchère entre bandes
nous conduisons des actions de
prévention mais nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui d'un fort relais de l'état
pour au delà de la prévention donner des
réponses
est-ce que les scènes dites moi si je me
trompe il y aurait une centaine de rixes
de ce genre il y aurait eu une centaine
de ces rixes l'an dernier sachant que la
france en compte à peu près 300 donc
c'est quand même un tiers de ce qui se
passe au niveau national dans l'essonne
99 fait sur 189 en ile de france c'est
un triste record même si notre
département c'est autre chose et
j'aurais vraiment dire aux
téléspectateurs que l'essonne c'est
aussi plateau de saclay saussines à
récurer innovant c'est aussi le téléthon
ce n'est pas que la délinquance et
jouerait pas con qu'on simplifie d'abord
de fait
identique mais c'est vrai que quand on à
99 est sur 189
il ya un vrai sujet qui nécessite une
vraie réponse de l'état structuré en
termes éducatifs répressive de
prévention une vraie chaîne de réponse
et s'attaquer véritablement de façon
individualisée à chaque conflit de bande
parce que sont les territoires les
origines sont différentes et donc les
réponses différentes on doit connaître
l'origine pour pouvoir apporter à chaque
fois une réponse appropriée ce qui
nécessite vraiment un travail fin un
maillage fin entre l'éducation nationale
les collectivités et les forces de
l'ordre et surtout une présence de
proximité
nous avons alerté depuis deux ans les
préfets successifs de l'essonne sur la
réorganisation des commissariats en
agglomération qui met un peu de distance
si vous voulez entre les forces de
l'ordre et la population je suis
notamment intervenu pour mon canton
d'arpajon la commissaire maintenant et à
saint john et des bois à s'éloigner et
donc il faut recréer de la proximité
entre les forces de sécurité les maires
principalement qui sont en charge de la
prévention de la délinquance
et puis les éducateurs les lieux
d'éducation les collèges les lycées
voilà donc un vrai travail fin qui doit
être conduit et c'est pas une réponse de
son policier on voit bien c'est très
nettement insuffisant nous faut du
personnel de greffe
il faut des magistrats il nous faut je
suis je suis membre d'un cancer
ministration d'un collège qui demande
depuis quatre ans un principal adjoint
qui mérite en termes d'effectifs
voilà c'est c'est un plan global pour
l'essonne il nous faut il la réponse ne
relève pas que du mystère l'intérieur
parce que ces jeunes sont très jeunes
justement est ce qu'il y a justement en
termes d'âge est ce que ces personnes
sont de plus en plus jeunes qu'elle est
la typologie justement de cette jeunesse
qui se battent banc de contrebande
je pense qu'il ya une grande diversité
ou c je pense pas qu'on puisse kata
l'aigle et quel tel type de jeunes je ne
rentrerai pas dans ce débat là encore
une fois il ya un phénomène qui est
massif mais des origines qui sont très
différentes
selon le lieu ça s'inscrit dans des
histoires qui remontent parfois une
dizaine d'années donc on est face à des
phénomènes qu'il faut vraiment
déconstruire qu'il faut appréhender
c'est à dire comprendre quelle est la
cause et après pouvoir apporter une
réponse efficace tant en termes
d'éducatif qu'en terme de de répression
donc je pense que ça serait extrêmement
réducteur de parler d'une catégorie de
jeunes ou d'un lieu puisque c'est un
phénomène qui est très répandue et on
voit bien là un fait à saint chéron que
je connais très bien je suis né à
dourdan les collégiens de mon village où
je suis mère vont dans ce collège donc
ses intérêts je connais très bien
c'est plutôt un territoire apaisé donc
vous voyez on n'est pas rée dans d
autres voilà il ya ce problème des
quartiers difficiles mais pas seulement
et je pense que ça serait réducteur si
vous voulez de dire voilà c'est qu'un
problème des quartiers c'est un problème
des quartiers mais pas seulement il ya
un vrai problème éducatif
merci beaucoup alexandre touzet de la
part de votre expérience de terrain ce
matin sur rtl france